hello freak [ __ ] politics is [ __ ]
exhausting but you can't people can't
live in the opposites like you can be
both thing you can be a great comedian
and you could also sexually it's all
people like you could be kind of
[ __ ] there but you're still a good
that doesn't don't you think that the
clue see gay thing was extra disturbing
because he was doing it to one of us
yeah wasn't he wasn't just doing it he
wasn't just saying hey girl stay still
while jerk-off from Friday which is
gross but he's also doing it too
well should be appear exactly and that's
what was one of the Kate's to me it's a
power dynamic and it's a you could have
had a sex work you could have jumped off
a sex worker would have been thrilled to
take your money
and you could do a scenario where you
blocked the door and you jerk off and
she's like but that's a consensual thing
that's why that indicates it meets at a
power struggle yeah because that
consensual thing doesn't give you the
buzz right yeah but like that also says
to me though that he Louie is so
intelligent that he did think it through
a little bit more than he's letting on
because it's like you know they're gonna
have to keep this secret because we're
all in this club together so if you do
it to a young comedian that thing you
don't know about that there's a certain
thing about stand-ups I think everybody
will agree were impulsive yep stand-ups
are impulsive people it's one of the
reasons why you'll say the funny thing
before everybody you know some people
might even not even entertain the
thought you open the door and then blurt
it out quicker than everybody else it's
there's an impersonal aspect there so
you think that could be an impulse no I
think that he's an impulsive guy I think
most comics are and there's a wild
thrill to that impulse the problem is
you're also doing it to a person that
doesn't want you to do it to them yeah
and even if you know there's no physical
contact you're making them watch you
beat off which is [ __ ] up and yeah you
know the whole TIG Notaro thing would
take Notaro thinks that he started
helping her to show that he was a nice
guy yes like a lesbian a feminist and
like he's gonna promote her thing and
this takes some of the weight off of him
right she said that she felt burdened by
her relationship with him because she
believes that he did it on purpose that
he made a conscious decision it could be
I don't know yeah me too you know it's a
good it's a good branding move it's a
good let's try and save the reputation
but I don't know I don't know but but
with that though it's like the when he
hosted SNL the monologue was about
pedophilia and he's like he needed it to
like eating a Snickers bar like you want
to touch that little kid so bad and you
know how horrible and how many wisent
ruined that how [ __ ] up it makes you
you know the kid and but you still do it
like that's what I think that with what
he did I'm like you really wanted to do
that real bad cuz comics all knew we
knew about it current I knew about it
five years ago I had heard it wasn't
true and I had heard from someone who
knows him better than me and I said well
what do you mean they they gave me like
this weird scenario where he was joking
around they were all joking around
together and then the story got out and
you know like he like pulled his dick
out like as a joke and everyone was
laughing and he it was like he was being
silly
and then the real story came out but
yeah you know I don't know we've had
people like Ari Shaffir was our podcast
he pulled us they I mean he did ask but
like that was fine I wanted to see his
dick I want to see vasectomies so we
wanted to see the scars I mean there was
a reason and then also that we had never
seen someone who was not circumcised
before and then he was like you want to
see it where they said yes
I walked up is that think about that
cutting baby dicks is so common you guys
gone through all your life to adulthood
any more than the average person she
fears the first dick that you saw that
wasn't sliced open as a baby it wasn't
arias dick that was uncircumcised this
was another these are two separate day I
can't believe I've never encountered an
uncircumcised penis super Jew of course
he's circumcised like I got the longest
balls in the game and I'm like I mean
shown to me like I want to see them and
I'm like dude I've seen arse dick and
balls multiple times comics you they're
not officially each other's dicks I've
never shown my [ __ ] to any what Chris I
seen your [ __ ] not I didn't like it
wasn't [ __ ] she didn't see your vagina
I saw it all yeah I saw the Steve yeah
[Applause]
[Music]